hannover lavelsloh kann meine lieben
freunde vor einigen tagen habe ich mit
sandra bereits ein video auf einem kanal
hochgeladen in dem du die was ist darf
ich dich nicht begleiten
ich habe mich meine haare heute
besonders schön finde ich noch damit die
welt mich auch überall sieht von norden
von links von rechts gemacht allerdings
soll es heute nicht um hüls richtung
gehen meine lieben freunde sondern wir
gerade schon gesagt vor zwei tagen habe
ich mir sagen wir ein video gemacht
indem du einen driving center ist
einfach bestanden habe du hast verkackt
[Musik]
das war praxisprüfung jetzt machen wir
die theorieprüfung eigentlich ist es
andersrum allerdings meinten sehr viele
leute von euch hellweger lustig wenn es
dann doch mal ein paar fragen
beantwortet deswegen hier sander 40
fragen hast heute okay also fangen
direkt mit der ersten situation du
kannst du hier dass er vorne direkt
anschauen
die frage ist worauf müssen sie sie
einstellen erstes auf querende personen
auf sichtbehinderungen oder auf sich
öffnen der fahrzeugtüren es können aber
auch mehrere sachen richtig sein
also das ist die a b und c und d glaube
ich gibt es nicht aber alles alles
falsch was doch richtig war mal weiter
mit der nächsten frage sie waren
mindestens 20 km h schneller als der
grüne lkw wie sollten sie sich verhalten
ich bremse ab und fahre hinter dem grün
lkw auf der autobahn ich fahre vor dem
grünen lkw auf die autobahn oder ich
halte mich am ende des einladenden
verein bildung streifen an und fahren
nach dem neuen lkw auf der autobahn
ich möchte nie autobahn fahren ich war
vor den grünen lkw weil ich habe beim
gehen müssen von der psg super ringe ja
frage 3 an einem bahnübergang in der ort
ist die schranke geschlossen wo müssen
sie warten vor der letzten wahl vor der
ersten bank oder vor dem andreaskreuz
andreaskreuz und was ist eine baracke
ich nehme weil auf a bedeutet einem
andreaskreuz wortmann
andreas kurz aber das ist halt dieses
bahnübergangs kreuz auf der andreas
sander kreuz
man muss aufsuchte lachten sie regieren
sein habe ich gar nicht führe den
überholvorgang zügig durchbrechen den
überholvorgang ab oder ich höre den
überholvorgang vorsichtig durch
zügig
denn flexen und so das ist verlass wir
haben wir wieder kein foto allerdings
steht hier aufgrund mehrerer verstöße
innerhalb der probezeit hat die behörde
die teilnahme an einem aufbauseminar
angeordnet das könnte es dann wirklich
zu sein
der fahranfänger kommt diese anordnung
nicht nach könnte es auch zu sein womit
muss er jetzt rechnen mit zusätzlichen
punkten im vereinsregister b mit einem
bußgeldbescheid oder c mit dem entzug
der fahrerlaubnis war ich deutschland
kenne und deutschland immer geld haben
will ist deutschland wieder einmal kein
geld haben respekt alter
wir haben fünf fragen oder 14
fehlerpunkte das heißt ich hätte die
theorieprüfung jetzt schon verpacken
jetzt sagt er mir dass meine fragen
schon vergangen frage nummer sechs wie
verhalten sie sich in dieser situation
wäre ein video also wir sehen dort ist
ein autofahrer der nach vorne fährt die
ampel ist grün geworden er hat hier
vorne das schild das sehen wir schon
dass er vorrang hat aber das ist eine
ampel von daher fährt geradeaus und ich
jetzt wenn du laberst kann mich ganz
konzentrieren ich bleibe hinter dem
radfahrer ich hoffe damit der radfahrer
platz macht oder ich überhole den
radfahrer also in der vorschau habe ich
gelernt man darf nie wo ich bleibe
hinter dem fahrradfahrer
ich glaube dass richtig weil es
durchgezogene linie und relativ wenig
platz wenn das jetzt keine durch dagegen
jetzt darf man da nicht überholen
ja also ich würde es allgemein infrage
stellen weil es eine sehr schmale straße
also haben wir nun eine ampel abgebildet
mit einem grünen pfeil nach rechts was
ist bei dieser ampel mit grünpfeil
schild erlaubt erst ins rechts abbiegen
aus dem oder weißt du schon
ja es richtig ist auch richtig so besser
ist nicht nur noch drei richtig um 4
falsch jetzt gerade mit müssen sie hier
rechnen ihr vater kann durch einen
starken sei wo ist denn der wind das
sieht man doch gar nicht was ihnen
vorfahren der vater kam nach rechts
gedrückt werden wenn sie überholen was
hast du mit seitenwind rechnen muss den
er wenn ich meinen weg begleiter noch
mal 500 kilo alter toten sondern erstmal
ihr fahrzeug kam durch seitenwind nach
links gerückt werden
das ihnen fahrende fahrzeug kam nach
rechts nach links oder save richtig ich
schwöre das sagt mein bauchgefühl ich
würde sagen a und c
das ist auch richtig weil wenn du halt
einem lkw vorbeifährt hast du halt nicht
mehr den seiten wie bei der lkw dem
blockiert sondern kann sein dass wenn du
die ganze zeit gegen längst hast du dann
ich sehe echt bitter schwarz bei dir im
frage nummer 9 sie fahren ein
langsameres fahrzeug auf einer
landstraße wie können sie schnelleren
fahrzeugen das überholen ermöglichen
durch ausweichen auf dem parkstreifen in
einer haltebucht oder auf den
seitenstreifen also bis auf einer
landstraße müssen langsam da mache ich
gar nicht platz alter häufig alter
meister aus dem prinzip dass ich
prozesse wo kannst du ein ausweichen
wenn du möchten natürlich nur alte buch
weil da war halte buch da steht ja schon
halten überall ja aus einem graben
vielleicht weniger du bist du hast so
schlecht alter nächste frage nochmals 10
haben wir wieder ein video also schauen
wir mal das video an ich lese
währenddessen schon mal die frage vor
wie verhalten sie sich richtig halte an
weil ein kind hinter dem transporter auf
die fahrbahn treten wird also schau dir
das jetzt gleich an was da passiert b
ich fahre langsam weiter weil kreiden
fußgänger erkennen bei den
fußgängerüberweg benutzen möchte oder
seh ich halte an weil einen mann den
fußgängerweg überqueren möchte also das
ist die situation
fr gl von 40 wo ist das halten verboten
im bereich von scharfen kurven auf
autobahnen und kraftfahrstraßen
außerhalb der parkplätze an bus und
haltestellen
das fahren auf der autobahn packen da
habe ich noch nie sich also bis auf
jeden fall schon mal richtig und im
bereich von scharfen kurven auch nicht
weil scharfe kurven dafür ich packe
schaffen dafür sind aber die anderen
nicht pa drücken aragon ja ich hätte ja
auch noch gedrückt man darf doch nicht
an bushaltestellen halten
der bus aber ich wir sind doch ein auto
nähert sich eine bahn überweg dessen
schranken geöffnet sind wir drüber flex
[Musik]
was wir warten hatte ich würde sagen wir
verringern das ganze video auf nur 20
fragen weil sonst sitzen wir morgen noch
also frage 13 1 lautete gehen das kann
ich gar nichts das ist das schlimmste
rems weg gefahren also als
geschwindigkeiten km/h durch 10 x 3
durch zwei oder geschwindigkeiten rahmen
km/h durch zehn mal fünf durch zwei oder
geschwindigkeiten km/h durch zehnmal
geschwindigkeiten haben km/h durch 10
durch 2
nada
fängt schon das erste problem ja gar
keine ahnung von gesang b aus gut glück
ich glaube ist sc ich weiß es auch nicht
mehr so genau aber ja man dürfe wenn du
bremst rechnet so in deinem kopf aus
sechs letzte frage sandra sie möchten
linksabbiegen in welcher reihenfolge
bereiten sie das abbiegen vor
fahrtrichtung anzeigen einordne
nachfolgenden verkehr beobachten
fahrtrichtung anzeigen einordnen oder
das einordnen fahrt richtung du musst
erst guckt mal deine was seine dumm mit
menschen macht damit du reagieren kannst
ja ist richtig nächste frage fünftletzte
wozu können bereits geringe mengen
alkohol führen aber verzögerte
reaktionen nachlassen der höheren
sehleistung zu riskante fahrweise
warum müssen sie hier die
geschwindigkeit verringern also die sich
schon dass videos geht 13 sekunden der
fahrer fährt ganz normal auf seiner auto
auf seine autobahn luca wahrscheinlich
wird auch der aufwand
rechts orangen ist kind warum kann das
befahren dieser straße gefährlich werden
weil schlecht beleuchtete fahrzeuge
schwer zu erkennen sind weil personen
auf der fahrbahn leicht zu übersehen
sind oder weil entgegenkommende
kraftfahrzeuge eher spät erkannt werden
die fragen kommen heftig bekannt vor die
habe ich letzte woche glaube ich noch
meine theorie app gemacht da müsstest du
sie wissen weil wenn ich mich ganz
falsch was anziehen als üblich keiner
deswegen auch immer schön diese ganzen
dinge an zwei schlecht beleuchteten
fahrzeuge schwer zu erkennen
das gibt es gibt ja keine schlecht
bezogenen fahrzeuge sprachen lernen also
ich soll jetzt die beamten dann weiter
okay ich glaube das ist falsch alles
klar ich hätte auch noch eine kreuzfahrt
meter hier deutschen reiter ihr habt
doch keine ahnung warum
selbst im ausland alltag von fragen hat
alle richtig dass ich jetzt mein
führerscheinalter drittletzte frage
einen radweg auf dem eine gruppe von
kindern fährt endet wo man muss
gerechnet werden dass die kinder
absteigen und warten bis alles frei ist
zu weit in die fahrbahn kommen oder
bedenkenlos auf die fahrbahn wechselte
ein genau so denke ich auf meinem
fahrrad okay das ist auch wieder falsch
vorletzte frage welches verkehrszeichen
gibt vorfahrt 3 2 oder 1 die leichteste
frage die ich hier gesehen habe sehen
wir machen letzte frage ist andere
personen will die fahrbahn auf dem
fußgängerweg überqueren wie verhalten
sie sich
ich überhole wartende fahrzeuge mit
besonderer vorsicht db ich bereite mich
auf das anhalten vor oder c ich überhole
nicht
ich bin ein ganzes zu meinem gehirn
denken beyoncé sind richtig überholen
nicht und das auch nicht
und das ist richtig sandra an der stelle
würde ich sagen allerdings beenden wir
jetzt auch den heutigen test eine
auswertung du hast du 43 fehlerpunkte 20
fragen du hattest acht richtig und zwölf
falsch also ich würde sagen herzlichen
glückwunsch du hast auch heute wieder
rein geschützt und meldet das video
allerdings sind auch gefallen hat auch
wenn sie wieder eingepackt hat anlass
auf jeden fall einen daumen hoch unter
dem video abonniert dem einen kanal fall
zog ein teil der ludwig seite und dann
ja jetzt alle zu mir fresse halten alter
[Musik]